Maslow's hierarchy of needs is a theory
in psychology it argues that there are
five stages of human needs that motivate
our behavior Abraham Maslow proposed his
theory in 1943 after studying what he
called exemplary people such as Albert
Einstein or Eleanor Roosevelt first
there are physiological needs such as
the need to breathe eat drink or sleep
the moment we get enough of that and we
feel awake and our bellies are full we
get motivated by the next thing now we
want safety we try to earn money build
up resources and look for shelter that
protects us against dangers once we are
satisfied and feel safe we have time to
think about what we want next at stage
three we seek love and belonging we
desire to be close to family and friends
belong to a society or join a gang but
the moment we feel completely part of a
group we already wish to be a little
different than the rest at stage four we
look for esteem self confidence and
respect from our peers we want to be
someone if we have money we buy a fancy
watch if we have a brain we write or
think or work a lot motivation to
perform and compete is now at its
highest students sports men and
inventors Excel Neil Armstrong even flew
to the moon only if we breathe and drink
and eat and sleep enough and we feel
safe and part of a group and still
special only then can we reach level
five self-actualization now we can relax
be creative
accept facts for what they are give back
or do whatever we want
no more pressure unless of course there
is trouble below
if you are a leader and believe in the
theory use it first make sure everyone
has eaten well then make them feel safe
and help them belong to a group once
they feel they belong they are ready to
stand out and excel thanks for watching
even if we try to keep it short each
video is quite some work first we've
research and write a script then we
brainstorm ideas and after that we draw
the storybook then it's recorded
narrated and finally edited if you want
to support us to make more videos on
learning and education visit patreon.com
slash sprouts
[Music]